vai vai vai vai quella continua
shakerare il culo in webcam perché ci
rimasta male
all
[Musica]
bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj e oggi ho deciso
di cambiare il mio [__] look perché
non è che posso andare in giro il
cappello de putin e ora di andarsene
questa casa sta diventando troppo
piccola per te che vivrai qua non potrai
fare più esperienze endo cazzo vado hai
voglia di spiegarmi come no vabbè se
scassato il computer regalo comprato
nuovo fa molto video visto che devo
andare a dormire domani vedo come
muovermi di casa visto che devo cambiare
casa domani me levo di culo me levo di
culo che in realtà ve la devo prima di
trovarlo a caso non è che me ne posso
andare così allora ghazi direi di
mangiare qualcosa andare a dormire
domani vediamo subito che cosa fare per
cambiare casa allora it sarà sicuramente
dal telefono per forza non vedono oggi
attività buongiorno hai passato tutta la
giornata a fare video ma sarei
stanchissima esatto brutta bagapsh
allora vedi n'è andata una bravissima
potesse funzionare così con le ragazze
sarebbe fantastico ci ho provato una
volta ho ricevuto una scarpata in bocca
allora ragazzi sono tanto sono pieno di
lampadine quindi posso fare un video
della madonna
però prima di farlo vuoi chattare amico
mio finché non porterei almeno una terza
una quarta dei dette hamelin è andata a
[__] tono molto selettivo nelle
amicizie ciao devo fare solo da una cosa
il computer solo un secondo ma cosa li
fa ma compratelo un computer ma cosa
vuoi
non è un computer donna quella la
console capisce il caso va bene un
importo hackerato il tuo social network
account sull'arrivo indietro pagami 100
dollari a cagare non ci credo mai ma
veramente mi aveva creato il canale ho
perso 3 mila iscritti malata piante
erculea come ha fatto non è possibile
volevo invitare per un film non odia che
stanno a gara i canali devo stabile
gameplay davide mi hanno creato il
canale necstour ometto questo titolo che
farà fare le big views non sarà di certo
il titolo che metterò altro video che
state vedendo credo o rega ci sarà un
modo per la tua casa
ah ecco costo mensile 320 dollari dai ce
la posso fare il nuovo a casa lega prima
di muovermi devo decidere che cosa fare
della mia compagna di
di distanza la mia compagna di stanza e
kick ass
ha quindi devo farla coco federica la
mano amica
ciao fa vj ho sentito che te ne vuoi
andare certo che la mia compagna di
stanza che mi chiama fa vj a calci nel
culo pesante già fa vj ho sentito che te
ne vuoi andare ma indovina un po perché
in un appartamento più grande perché hai
bisogno di più spazio sicuro di non
voler farmi venire con te commento
accompagna
ma
tesoro scusami scusa mi va bene va bene
grazie per la tua offerta ma mi piace
vivere qui quindi non ho bisogno allora
te ne vai a fan culo che hai fatto tutto
lo spiegone poi ti va bene dov'è allora
stai qua che cazzo vuoi veramente
incredibile ne sto già andando veramente
prima dei centomila iscritti ho cambiato
casa due volte c'è ciao proprio così
no vabbè non ci credo che figo è la
madonna quanto è grossa sta a casa e più
grossa di casa mia c'è anche piano di
sopra
va bene ma che figata mio nuovo
appartamento è molto molto più grande e
molto più figo io ho iniziato a creare
il mio youtube game
quindi adesso posso creare un team di
per fare video insieme c'è il piano di
sopra laga non ci posso credere non ci
credo
no vabbè ma è bellissimo la mia casa
nuova nuova bella grossa più grossa ecco
ragazzino ora che a 95 mila iscritti
siamo quasi a 100.000 primo il traguardo
della madonna assurdo stai perdendo
iscritti devi fare più video aspetta che
appena cambiato casa un attimo cristo
devi montare il video e poi vai a
dormire ce la puoi fare
resiste la paura come si chiama da
novanta è stanco ci siamo ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta ho fantastico regalo
sono troppo contento di essere riuscito
a fare sti due video anche se sbaglio
matera sta a casa visto che ciò la casa
nuova regaliamo di fare un po di
acquisti di cose idea siamo andiamo
all'idea per comprare i nuovi mobili
giusto schumann giu tristar va bene
mycroft grip e a chi parla è scritto
giusto per questo compro subito
bellissimo stanno per fare un party
fantastico vuoi unirti a noi va bene zia
face kraft spacecraft è bellissimo
compriamo assolutamente vai sono troppo
contento di aver fatto questi acquisti
utilissimi per youtube a domandare
all'evento vabbè mi si possa togliere il
suo cappello che da una vita che ce l'ho
mi fa cagare maglia rigorosamente rosa e
andiamo a comandare perfetto guarda che
stile un vero uomo cazzo 100mila
iscritti sono arrivati al 100 mila
ragazzi dobbiamo andare a festeggiare
vai
ora vedo che ci sta gente messa peggio
di me coi vestiti meno male ma ciao zio
da posto vorreste essere la mia compagna
di stanza a youtube ma dona che tette ma
ora come sono bravo a socializzare che
subito diventare amici gli altri fa
veigy ben times
eppure nerd so che c'è una maglietta che
a dir poco imbarazzante però se ti
semmai che andasse di venire a casa mia
facciamoli video un altro ragazzi asta
festa qua mi ha invitato la mia ragazza
che non sto neanche vedere eccola qua io
e io sto parlando con un altro a
carissimo va bene ne sono rimorchiata
un'altra lega che nun iocca paura hai un
sacco di iscritti è visto che un sacco
di iscritti ci viene a fare le cose
sporche
mi piacciono i tuoi video fa vj ma
quando li ha guardati quando hai avuto
tempo di guardarli che siamo qua che
stava a parlare a cinque minuti se vi
state chiedendo ragazzi quale la tattica
migliore per rimorchiare una ragazza è
questa
vedi come sta funzionando di brutto
questa qua un altro po me lo ha dato che
i ragazzi me la sono rimorchiata pesante
perché voglio che lei sia la mia
compagna di video
ho passato tutta la pensa rimorchiarli
sta tizia con la chiamo e le dico di
venire a casa mia
reilly stiamo insieme a spec e sto
parlando di stigma globe ero arrivato a
100.000 non sono più a 100 mila iscritti
la sua famiglia mito che questi casi di
si scrivono mango posso rimorchiare
agente si descrivermi che cazzo è anche
un po di vita sociale possa vevo youtube
dio mio
la storia della mia vita ho rimorchiato
una tipa che minghia nome la da subito
la merda live e dei miei video mi son
dimenticato sta cosa
questo potrebbe essere un problema e
prove chat con le devo aspettare che il
video sia carico per chattare per
chattare mi compra un po di cibo la
famiglia
ecco la zia come stai ma certo che vengo
a vedere un film con te
aspetta aspetta aspetta ma devo comprare
roba da mangiare giusto spaghetti
bolognese vai corniche cesta al film
vuoi chattare ma semmai appena invitato
un film che devo citare ragazzi sto per
andare a vedere un film con la mia
tipiche wow
ecco perché non è la mia tipa per niente
però registra un intervista perché posso
farne un intervista
beh a tutti ragazzi inizia così video
fai un sacco di virus e chi stai
sbagliando mi carica questo video
raggiunge il milione tra poi qua cesta
jet set di guy la pressione intervistata
risponde no a una lunga domanda mar de
rose look
ok questa se questo è solo intervistando
gex etica e lui risponde che un migliore
youtuber di the man doti vedi zio ma è
che assistenti che pari uno che ci hai
capelli al pistacchio e questo è
diventato il maurizio costanzo show sto
video sentiti a fleur diamo un attimo
che tenevo rimorchi a pesante tu devi
essere alla mia compagna di video non
hai capito bene mi abbraccia mi
abbraccia l'altra non mi abbraccia
neanche per sbaglio fatto stiamo
arrivando alla tacchetta tra può
veramente diventare mia fidanzata
guardali adesso posso chiederle di un
appuntamento ma posso chiedere di fare
video con me air collaborator funziona
così triste ma perché pensi che io ti
guarda ma cosa fate ma non così deve
essere la tua ragazza allo stesso tempo
come a era triste perché li voleva
essere la mia ragazza invece avevo
chiesto di fare video insieme a me ma va
bene chi se ne frega ce nel senso
possiamo essere un ragazzo siamo stoppa
uguale no vabbè aspetta regala ho fatto
una cagata posso tornare indietro
ma no lei deve essere la mia ragazza
assolutamente no ci sono rimasto
malissimo ma ora che ci rimasta male ma
poverina ma vi giuro io non volevo far
questo
all
no
nike
nato male da è un videogioco liscio
piano male per una cosa che non è finta
non volevo lega
porca [__] fatto un altro kata
incredibile da e mi chiama orribile di
senza una verdara volevo guadagnare ex
lì a schio for all election ship
potresti diventare la mia ragazza
se non risponde di nove ma risposto di
no sa rincoglionita lavelli mettetevi in
fila in cammello dentro la volont i
meriti il mio amore brutta [__] e
se lo meritava e l'ho deluso o centomila
iscritti o nome levi rompe puoi
andartene adesso fa vj grazie per essere
venuto grazie ad esso non mi dice più
che non sono abbastanza famoso è
deficiente anzi in realtà in realtà
questo non è neanche frentano questa e
youtube zone ancora peggio scusami ma ti
vedo soltanto come una youtuber o
youtube e donato una tipa contro la mia
volontà cioè questa è veramente una
tragedia sono tutta sta roba vai vai vai
vai quella continua a scegliere il culo
in webcam avaya turca da un'altra parte
di mortacci tua
a posto fa niente quindi ok bene la
smetti di pestarmi la playstation che
nuova che fossi novara ragazzi che non
credo che il video è stato bello c'è
veramente mi guarda mi dispiace di
averla perdonata così tanto la tizia
però veramente vi giuro non volevo e
poco è successo e ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto come se vi è piaciuto al
solito ha lasciato il commento è un mi
piace anche a pacelli facebook e come
nel video trattare descrizione
ricordatevi che se volete chiedere alle
tipi di fare video con voi ricordatevi
un attimo prima di legare che potete
anche averla una relazione nel mentre
però potrebbero non capirlo
vabbè se non sei ore si discute non ci
vediamo al prossimo video beh ragazzi